les shérifs de il ya autour de cette
table quelqu'un qui est amoureux moi et
j'ai les preuves
cette fois ci je les ai autant la
semaine dernière je n'avais pas de
preuves autant cette semaine je les ai
je vais faire un tour de table pour
cette personne dira à son avis qu qui
est la personne amoureuse une autre
personne au sein de tpm p
castaldi
mathieu
médailles
guillaume ok je ne sais pas du tout bah
c'est pas d'isabelle non mais peut-être
que j'aime bien mais ils se connaissent
depuis des années je sais pas mais je
sens que ça peut être un coeur
d'artichaut comme ça qui tombe amoureux
normal alors un garçon qui aime la vie
qui aime l'amour voilà tu sais les
feuilles
j'aime la vie essien inhabituel
artichauts et stephen walt nord
jean-michel pense à sophie je pense
depuis deux mois
que dit jean mi c'est un lover je pense
que ça lui un over depuis quatre mois
soixante personnes au public à wasquehal
a abouti avec la personne le reste voilà
vous le dis ça s'est terminé ce n'est de
la boule un an d'août à l'e10 dont
maladie non ma team pour moi c'est jean
michel il est toujours amoureux donc
l'aide de sophie secrètement guy lux
mathieu ah oui 2 qui de lui même
[Applaudissements]
ça n'est pas la bonne réponse faute on y
est une chaise est une chaise mais parce
que si la personne est d'accord elle
amènera sachets c'est le keller à
s'asseoir à la panacée des rideaux
ont-ils moi je pense à mathieu besoin de
séduire en permanence quelqu'un dans
l'entourage de l'émission où quelqu'un
auprès de vous pas un chroniqueur
directement mais comme vous dites que
c'est secret quelqu'un autour je pense
qu isabelle mathieu de vous mais c'est
parce qu'il n'a pas entendu l'autre jour
que vous disiez vous ne supportiez même
pas les suppositoires on al'avantage de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet
merci mamie et un coton-tige comble tu
as écouté je suis content d'apprendre
que vous avez un coton tige dans le slip
sophie je tirais benjamin roure oui moi
aussi
bravo non mais ça veut rien dire des
fois tu sais ça veut rien dire on peut
avoir une meuf akeson comme benjamin
fall en mesurer combien sophie dalès à
113,1 m 73 où il pense lui pense que
vous faites un mètre cinquante trois
[Rires]
lattes yeux allaient radieux battu
quelques mois c'est la réponse au chaud
donc c'est pas très drôle ce que jeune
équipe dont je remets la ici c'est
sophie oui elle est célibataire et mali
tout à l'heure mais laissez-le finissait
pas c'est sophie doki
ça je ne dirai pas si si tu dois le dire
aussi toutes les vérités ici alors si on
dit toute la vérité je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose qui est en train de se
passer entre sophie et jean michel bon
goûter avait quand même on en apprend
tous les maux qui nous rejoignent en
direct sachez que je n'ai pas le coeur à
rire clicquot les galéjades et j'ai le
coeur serré avec et le bagage à main
m e charles aznavour
sachez qu'il ya quelqu'un qui aime une
autre personne au sein de touche pas à
mon poste c'est un admirateur et
laissez-les admirateurs se séparer et
bien lui c'est un admirateur pas secret
du tout c'est un homme est un homme qui
est amoureux un homme qui veut conclure
par tous les moyens
un homme qui a envie d'aller loin avec
l'autre personne ne le rende par la main
et de courir courir dans l'herbe avec
chatouiller les globules soit pas dans
un instant duras btp balances ton papa
bûcheron le débat et les cherry est ce
que vous voulez la preuve en images
non mais bon on a dû savourer un indice
à la traîne savoir qu'elle allait sur
l'attribution à personne mais c'est une
personne de ce côté-ci en tee shirt
s'est battue alors oui j'avais mes amis
donc ce émeutes urbaines
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rezaï
[Musique]
bah ça
c'est pire
que la puce
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mathieu mathieu non non non je ne suis
pas un bâtard qui veut rapprocher
d'autres personnes non
et pour cela je vous ai reconstituer une
table au restaurant aux chandelles au
mélo sauf que la bougie n'est pas allumé
mais la bougie s'allumera si la momie
accords étendant des mondes si l'amour
est au rendez-vous allumera t-il la jib
où je vais l'appeler thomert et si c'est
lui qui nous a demandé à mes joues 10 et
13 grâce à ce qui nous donne mandat l'ex
à bien nos instants vous allez vous
asseoir c'est lui qui dès demanderez
vous allez vous asseoir à la table alors
savais pas du tout que ça oui bah oui
sinon j'aurais jamais je ne vais pas le
forcer cette fouille quoi alex qui voit
là il nous a demandé au maire alex que
j'aime énormément qui comme avec moi
depuis les années jeanne amoureuse mais
un choix
alex c'est très simple
il va rentrer et qui va vous le dire il
va y avoir il va avoir deux choix alex
un chopper applaudissements pour alexia
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
car après on sait que je t'aime est à
côté de moi il fait un travail pendant
que ça soit il était prévu et moi je lui
dit il je dis tu sais que je t'aime il
m'a dit de même avec mon chéri tu
travailles quoi depuis combien de temps
tiendront alors alex faut que vous
sachiez au départ c'était une grande
rigolade parce qu'en fait alex c'est lui
qui s'occupait en fait parce que j'ai un
jet un minibar mais il ya que des
boissons au genre oasis rec a light
bullois son volvic tout ça et alex au
départ il s'occupait juste de ça en fait
au tout début et c'est très drôle parce
que tous les soirs ils venaient dans ma
loge à la fin et prenez une photo du
frigo ouvert pour voir les boissons qui
avaient été consommées c'est bon pas mon
chéri non et on a fait voilà on avait
dérivé a donc je lui dis tu rencontres
un jour à ma femme à voir les photos à
des remises à atari siècle à des tas de
bois ce coup voilà mon chéri mon alex
c'est vrai que matthieu delormeau ne te
lâche pas un peu trop collant mai mais
ça va venir de cette séquence les
relations des sept secteurs mathieu
avant qu'alexandre à bannalec sens
d'avoir le choix
oui alexandre d'un garçon on aime tous
ici dans l'ic 12e
mathieu est ce que vous avez quelque
chose à dire à alexandre
je vous forcez qu'alexandre va accepter
de dîner avec vous puisque vous y avait
proposé une pizza le rappel à l'ordre
est lavé dans les images suivantes un
garçon de qualité des coups très simple
très familiaux qu'elle est très jolie
valeur j'ai beaucoup d'ambition pour lui
que ce soit h 2 o ailleurs c'est un
garçon très intelligent
voilà donc voilà je souhaitais dédier
tout est beau comme on le trouvait beau
oui oui quand vous savez le physique
c'est très aléatoire
il aurait été moche que je ne l'aurais
eu autant de talent donc je je
souhaitais déjeuner avait pour parler de
son évolution de carrière d'accord de
son évolution carrière mathieu autre
évolution est ce que de supprimer ses
portes c'est bon alors juste alors avant
de décider si vous acceptez de faire un
dîner avec mathieu et nous donner votre
réponse dans un instant oui je vous dis
pas qu'il va dire une tête qui va dire
non alexandre est ce que vous trouvez
mathieu sympa dans les coulisses il est
très sympa avec moi mais comme la
plupart des chroniqueurs ils sont sympas
aussi avec moi tout le monde est sympa
victoire ouais franchement oui
est-ce que tu le trouve drôle ça dépend
des fois très droit d un grand mot mais
que tu trouve intelligent non
pas vraiment alexandre mathieu t'a
proposé une pizza je vais demander à mes
dix on a mimé d'y aller avec toi tu te
trouves qua non mais je trouve quand
même sympathique en gteam pas tellement
intelligent et pas une lumière tu es une
bougie était pas un halogène et par
rapport à la base des autres
chroniqueurs ça dépend la chronique
c'est le moi pour toit s'était alors
j'ai pas dit que c'était plus con des
chroniqueurs et il est dans le top 3
vous y verrez par la faim qu'elle n'est
pas dans le trio de tête
c'est très simple alexandre tu vas avoir
de choix
je vais demander à mes dix de m'amener
une pizza et départ
[Applaudissements]
vrai
pas du tout
zéro j'adore la france
voilà privé et on a des moyens d'où ils
sont pris comme un comédien pour venir
sera encore n'est pas lui il s'appelle
commence qu'à 100 parce qu'il est très
fort j'aime beaucoup elle est bien tard
ni d'hamilton et immersif et respecté à
4h bas alors c'est très simple mathieu
vous l'avez vu chez vous c'est vrai que
vous avez proposé alexandre guerrier
mais alexandre dayon tu peux dire aux
téléspectateurs
en quoi consiste son travail pour qu'ils
comprennent un petit peu je suis
régissant la journée elle s'y sent real
eux le soir le direct du fait que courir
entre autrui je m'occupe aussi des
accessoires pour les chroniqueurs
pancartes
quand il ya des happenings à préparer
les jeux puis veiller à que l'émission
ce à quoi même que des accessoires tu
n'as pas envie
voilà pour l'instant du possible c'est
que la télé paris le vendredi s'occupe
de moi comme ça qu'on s'est rapproché de
type d'accord oui enfin on va alors vous
avez proposé parce qu'alexandre peut
peut-être accepter ce tri entre vrais
proposé alexandre une pizza
parce qu'il est beaucoup plus tôt non
mais non vous avez proposé une pizza
c'est très simple alexandre soit tu
décides de ta table et avec mathieu pour
partager cette pizza
et ça signifiera que tout n'est pas mort
et que vous pouvez aller déjeuner ou
dîner ensemble prochainement cours soit
tu décides de repartir seul comme garou
avec les spaghettis sauldre à quoi tu
pourras manger chez toi loin de là que
ça signifiera que pour mathieu
comme pour le géant vert c'est la fin
des haricots non alexandre je vais te
demander de faire trois pas en arrière
je crois que je connais la maison un
jour et plusieurs mesures car alexandre
je vais te demander à mon top
de partir et de te diriger ouvert le
plat de pâtes
si tu décides de repartir tout seul et
de ne jamais déjeuné ou dîné avec
mathieu ouvert la pizza su décide de
donner une chance à mathieu et de
déjeuner ou dîner avec lui fait le match
et peut dire un dernier mot pour le
convaincre
bien sûr je pense que mathieu a son mot
à dire car ensuite alexandre c'est avant
tout approchera ou des pâtes ou de la
pizza
je rappelle aux téléspectateurs pizza
c'est bon pat je me avons écrit pizza
c'est pas de ces cui bravo fou
ce
maintenant c'est comme ça que je décide
ce qui me disent l inverse à nancy lui a
proposé de prendre une pizza 6 points la
pizza thick as we know it all away
depuis quand dans le réel tour de 10 kw
est cette personne est viré alors mardi
battus alors alexandre lemay chemin que
je me suis un garçon extrêmement gentil
je m'intéresse aux autres j'ai beaucoup
d'ambition pour toi j'ai joli garçon
mais il y en ad'autres d'être un joli
garçon
donc c'est passe quelque chose plus
difficile à trouver surtout
malheureusement quand on fait de la
télévision
malte est parfois pour de mauvaises
raisons voilà les miennes sont nobles
je sais voilà absolument donc voilà je
suis gentil en coulisses je te parle
toujours je m'intéresse à toi je sais où
tu vis la vidéo un petit village en
auvergne je voudrais dire où il se
serait quand même enseigne est donc
voilà on garantit que le très bonne
valeur
je pensais avoir également de penser à
voir également voilà donc donc donc
donc voilà donc donc voilà c'est un
garçon qui est très très sympathique
on s'émeut rien le dîner ou déjeuner
avec lui est ce que tu es amoureux non
c'est pas la question je joue devant
n'est pas amoureux comme on achète une
bagnole je les propose effectivement de
déjeuner avec udine avec parce que parce
qu'on s'entend bien parce que voilà
parce que je trouve qu'il est il et il
est il et il est touchant et non alors
il vous plaît allez c'est bon on a eu
vos arguments voilà alex mon chéri tu
vas partir de là et tu vas aller vers
ton destin ou la pizza
où les pasta pizza ou pas c'est le très
belle maison dans le sud et je prends le
cas et après je pars direct ou si vous
si je prends je vais directement là où
sans explication alors je vais te dire
un je pense que tu donneras quelques
explications au trot
non il peut en donner quelques sous ou
bien toi tu préfère prendre le plateau
barry prendre la place je prends de la
pizza et asseoir tu fais ce que tu veux
comme tu le sens citant des données les
explications temps donne si t'as pas
envie tu prends la pizza tu vas
t'asseoir avec lui et vous irez
dinosaures sinon tu prends les pattes et
bien entendu tu va les manger en
coulisses mais si tu veux me donner
quand même ce sera le jeune alexandre
clôture a pris sa décision
tu te dirigera vers ton destin
et tous les
ou les pâtes du destin ou la pizza du
destin c'est loupé
la pizza c'est moi alex la pizza c'est
bon il donnera pour la pizza et
s'associera x mettra l'a oublié prend
les pattes et il partira
loin de tout ça alexandre la france est
pendu à tes lèvres et pondu acquis par
alexandre sache que ce que tu vas faire
c'est un petit pas pour l'homme mais un
grand pas pour mathieu d'hollande tous
que 2020 j'ai lu que pour moi c'était le
l'année de l'amour est l'année où je
devenais une meilleure personne ah oui
on va dire qu'une chose à écouter
attentes et surtout 2021 sur le mot alex
c'est à toi
[Musique]
oh
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
alors si non mais parce que c'est bon et
claire même été très gentil tout ça pas
de souci mais même les chroniqueurs au
613 gentil mais jeudi les autres
chroniqueurs pour autant non plus et
vous voilà si tu veux dîner en guerre on
fera un dîner tous ensemble oui mais
voilà avec tous les chroniques toutes
les personnes qui travaillent ici je
peux garder moi la bouteille de
champagne vous regardez moi la bouteille
mais alex a été très sympathique avec
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces cadeaux râteau doigt la france
entière et tu ajout du malade et très
sympathique qu'est ce que ça aurait été
s'il avait été désagréable
il a été plutôt calme et poli voilà une
des diplomates y lâchez un peu mais il
est très sympa n'auriez vous adore alors
franchement ils vous adore mais voilà il
avait mal géré une égale à 10 qui
dealent avec aucun des chroniqueurs